Hey everyone Diavolo here and in todays
video we are getting that good good,
hhmmmm. Like there's probably some of the most
over-powered techniques and fattest infodumps
revealed to us here throughout this video that
are super integral to the overall outcome of
this overbearing saga that is the culling game
and really just the entire story in general. So
if you are keen and want me to keep pumping
out content just like this but for a variety
of different series then make sure to hit
that subscribe button and push this video
to 5k likes so I know ya all want the Hisoka v
Chollo beatdown that i've begun scripting BUT
ANYWAY MOVING FORWARD into the 13th arc of Gege
Akutami’s beast of a series that is Jujutsu Kaisen
Kicking things back off again, we shoot over to
Tokyo Colony No.1, where Hana Kurusu mysteriously
greets an awaking Megumi as "My Fated One."
Still dozy, Megumi asks how long he was out
for? with Yuji who’s looking like a KING
dripped out in the robe sipping on some
wine remarks that he has been unconscious for two
days, and it is now almost the 15th of November.
Having collected some food, Takaba enters the
room, and as Hana settles on the couch with a
tub of ice cream, the group discuss how its
quiet odd that the powers still on in Tokyo.
Megumi presumes that Kenjaku may have colluded
with the higher ups to keep the power on so it
wouldn't interfere with the game itself.
He then goes to take a dump and because he
was out of action for a few days asks to be
filled in on what happened while he was out.
Its explained that, Yuji bumped into Takaba and
choose to join forces in an attempt to locate
Megumi. Eventually Takaba was able to locate Hana
carrying Megumi, and that's how they all ended up
together. Bringing him fully up to date, Yuji
shows Megumi how many points both Hakari and
Yuta have, telling him that including his own
and Takaba’s points they've met their quota.
Now all that's left is to figure out how many
points are needed to actually leave the game.
Curiously Megumi turns and asks Hana if she’s the
player named "Angel" they were looking for and
also why she saved him in the first place. As Hana
confirms who she is a mouth suddenly Suddenly, a
mouth appears on the side of her face telling them
to cut asking a chick so many questions, leaving
everyone stunned bar Yuji says who exclaims that
its someone like him. Answering Megumi’s Question,
Angel goes to tell him why he was saved but Hana
randomly cuts off obviously hiding something.
Continuing Angel (which is the incarnated sorcerer
inside of her if anyone's confused) explains
exactly how her technique works. Simply it negates
cursed techniques, seals, and barriers, because of
this it allows her to freely travel between
colonies, hence how she was in Tokyo Colony
2 as they originally thought. The reason she
left that colony though was because of her main
goal which is to “purge all incarnated players”
and Tokyo 2 was over saturated in cursed spirits.
Her reasoning for this is because the vessels
of incarnated players are usually suppressed
and destroyed upon incarnation, which
goes against the "Laws of God." Therefore,
Angel chose to coexist with Hana. Megumi asks if
she could use its cursed technique to free Gojo,
to which she affirms its possible, but first
wants something in return. THE DISGRACED ONE OR
THE FALLEN, she promises to the boys that if they
manage to take him down she wont hesitate to help.
Well let me tell you all, things certainly take
an interesting turn as Yuji is summoned to his
or Sukuna’s inner world. Stepping forth both
loathe each other's sight, yet, there isn't
any messing around this time. No Sukuna, the
"King of Curses" reveals himself to be "The
Disgraced One". Which absolutely flips the series
on its head, and let me tell you all right now. Ya
aint ready for what's about to happen, I still
cant fathom the reality that is 213. Anyways!
Noticing that something's up with his boy,
Megumi calls out his name, asking him if
he’s okay. Looking like he freaking died on the
inside, Yuji says he really aint feeling well,
and asks Hana to swap places with him so he can
lie down. Mans suffering after just realizing
he’s being hunted by yet another ancient
sorcerer. Having moved out of Hana’s pov,
Yuji begins trying gesture that
the disgraced one is Sukuna.
Man I actually love Megumi’s confused ass
face, eventually though and after sitting
down with Hana, he realizes what Yuji is trying
to say. Megumi though roughly ponders on how they
need her help to save Gojo, but now their
completely back at square one as her target
is technically Yuji. Similarly Yuji muses about
why Sukuna told him to keep quiet and concludes
that Angel must have some sort of ability that
can completely obliterate Sukuna without any
chance of return. Yuji being Yuji thinks
is a cheap price to pay to end the curse
and decides that as soon as the others implement
the rules required to save Tsumiki, he will die.
With the two comparatively overthinking everything
Angel speaks again breaking their thoughts and
remarking that it’s odd how a large number
of people are currently entering the colony.
Quickly the group command their Kogane
to show the current Culling Game
player base with it revealing 807 active
players, with more joining every minute.
So right now in the story with Yuji
n stuff were in November of 2018.
Well taking things back a few months of
February we find Kenjaku and Sukuna’s
Chef Uraume explaining to U.S. officials the
existence of cursed energy and cursed spirits.
So apparently curses are usually only observable
by the Japanese population with some exceptions,
this includes the fact that they are mostly
invisible to the naked eye. Curses and cursed
energy live within wavelengths of visible light,
but the normal human brain cant pick it up and
man made camera’s don't capture the correct
light to view what's actually happening.
Which btw if you’ve watched Jallomoths dope
video going over the Jujutsu Kaisen iceberg,
well it goes into the theory that Jujutsu
Kaisens cursed realm is the same place as
in Gege Akutami’s first story called No. 9.
In which the main character who I think looks
like a mix of Sukuna/Gojo and Megumi uses weapons
and Shikigami like creatures that he summons from
9 different boxes that interact with a shadowy
realm. Plus remember that one time Sukuna told
that Black Box to open before he uses a flame
arrow to send Jogo to the cursed realm. Which btw
if you didn't know as well, curses see their realm
as white not black, hence how after Jogo comes to,
back in the curse realm everything is now
white around him. Ah honestly I need to move
on right now otherwise ima just start dropping
series changing theories that I head cannoned.
Anyways so after having
handed out the cursed glasses,
Uraume lets everyone there know that
they function as a screen and will
allow them to see curses along with other
manifestations made with cursed energy.
Instantly after placing on the glasses, the
US president along with his secretaries react
in shock horror asking what kind of disgusting
trick this is. Cyrus, one of the US presidents
officials speaks up, telling them to calm down
as they’d already been able to confirm that
this is all reality and if they don't cease this
opportunity they’ll fall behind as a global power.
The two sorcerers then exorcize the cursed
spirits, assuring the officials that they mean
no harm. Elaborating some more on how curses don't
appear on camera, Uraume states that they have
video footage recorded using jujutsu technology
that works by capturing a puppet’s vision.
Specifically they show footage to the officials
that was taken through kokichi’s puppets vision,
giving them a taste of Sukuna, Gojo, Nanami,
and Todo’s abilities. The President makes
a joke about it not being Imax. However,
secretary Cyrus declares that they just don't get
it yet, cursed energy has the potential to become
the cleanest energy source in history, replacing
every other form of known energy on the planet.
Cyrus stresses that even the blonde
dude they just watched throw hands
possesses enough cursed energy to power
an entire country. Sitting before them,
the body swapping goon then informs them
that in November, Tokyo will become a domain
of pure viscousness where all jujutsu
users will be forced to congregate for
a ritual. Hearing this and becoming enraged,
The President of the good old USA demands to
know if he’s being told to kidnap Japanese
citizens and use them as research subjects.
Standing up himself, Cyrus insists on the
importance of tapping into cursed energy as
an alternative energy source. He emphasized that
sorcerers defied modern science and technology
because their brains were wired differently.
However, the whole idea of abducting people
for human experimentation truly horrifies the
President. In an attempt to fully convince the
big P, Cyrus goes on a mad rant, citing various
nations like China, Russia, Saudi Arabia and
the Middle East who would surpass them as a
world power if they didn't do anything soon..
Beginning to twist facts, he declaring that their
operation would be a form of protection for the
Japanese people against other countries that could
targeted them indiscriminately, sorcerer or not.
His advisor also suspected that because
this negotiation was being kept under wraps,
their failure to comply would force Kenjaku
to negotiate with other countries. Having
over heard them, Kenjaku added that because
sorcerers were a minority even among Japanese
citizens, the November gathering would be an
excellent opportunity to collect specimens.
Btw Big Kenjaku is an absolute hoe as he’s managed
to comfortably convince the higherups of all large
world powers that he’s the sorcerer Suguru Geto,
man is out to absolutely destroy Suguru’s name.
Knowing that there are Japanese descendants
in the US, The President orders them to
be heavily guarded in order to protect
them from attacks by foreign countries.
Quickly following this he then
turns and asks big Garry K,
the special operations commander how many
soldiers they should deploy. Gary who calls
himself a military man (like bruh we all figured
that one) asks for more confirmation about the
average strength of sorcerers, to gauge
how many men he needs to actually deploy.
After learning that the main threat in
Gojo would be locked away in November.
Gary becomes confident that one battalion
of 60 soldiers would suffice, given that
the sorcerers were all amateurs. He declared
that even with their supernatural abilities,
they couldn't compete with the skill, weapons,
and experience of trained US army soldiers.
Kenjaku casually agrees BUT states he’d still
recommend a full battalion of at least 800
soldiers to deal with the sorcerers effectively.
Hearing this, Gary dismisses the idea,
mocking the Japanese people and pretty
much calling them weak and pathetic.
Speaking up, Uraume proposes a test
and moments later Kenjaku snidely
guessed that the 15 men guarding the
meeting room defiantly wasn't everyone.
So I always lose it here, but the meeting
actually ends and the Special ops manager
goes in-depth about how in addition to the
15 secret-service agents guarding the room,
men from SAC, the C.I.A.'s paramilitary division,
were patrolling the White House. Along with them
there’s another 45 elite soldiers ready to bring
down "Suguru Geto." Having moved from the east
to west side of the building, they believe that
Geto would never be able to defeat all of them.
In the West office and wanting to wrap this up
Geto gets ready to unleash his technique in a show
of dominance. Opposite them, crazy Gary states
that these silly old Japanese people should stick
to anime and cars. Right now they’re objective
isn't to just win, but to instead present such
an overwhelming show of force as that is AMERICA!
Instead tho mans instantly shocked when all of his
soldiers began falling from the sky oblivious to
how it even happened. Though after chucking on his
sunny’s Gary finally realizes the TRUE HORRIFYING
power that is Curse Spirit Manipulation.
Back inside, Kenjaku throws down all
45 name tags in front of the President,
asking if they now understand.
So coming back to sometime in November
and first of all, mind if I blow your mind
for a moment? well remember Riko? Well she
wasn't the only one that was a Star Plasma
Vessel. Yuki was also compatible, but the
reason Tengen chose Riko was because no one
existed with her potential making her the
idea vessel. Which just gets me wondering,
is Yuji someone who’s compatible with Sukuna
because he also fits the same potential as a
vessel, idk its just an idea i've had while
scripting. Let me know your thoughts below.
When Yuki demanded to know why Tengen had
risked not merging with another Vessel,
the immortal sorcerer stated that
they had simply accepted reality.
Tengen knew that it would eventually happen and he
might become a threat to humanity upon evolving,
but reasoned that they could retain their sanity
using barrier techniques. Which makes sense,
as Tengen is the most proficient
barrier user currently known in
the series, with Sukuna being the
greatest RTC user of all time.
Incensed by the explanation, Yuki
asks a really damn good question,
“was it reasonable to burden children with
his own responsibilities? Like its just sad,
this thumb of man doesn't see the Star Plasma
Vessels as humans, but more as just expendable
pieces and that's why Yuki was so peeved
with how he casually disregarded them.
Thinking on the past now, Yuki grumbles that
she could have helped the Star organization
if their aim was to simply prevent the
merging, instead of killing off the Vessels.
Its then revealed that Yuki is able to hear
the voices of past Star Plasma vessels, unlike
Tengen itself. Tengen asked Yuki to tell them
what the voices were saying, but Yuki refused,
stating that the immortal sorcerer would use
those words to justify their decision to evolve.
Sighing over not really getting anywhere, Tengen
states they would've like to chat some more,
yet they’re unable too as its shown that
the megalomaniac, body swapping feign,
Kenjaku was able to break through and enter
the area above the Tombs Of The Star Corridor.
If you remember from way back in the perfect
prep arc, well Choso was teamed up with Yuki
to protect Tengen from this exact issue. Due to
this, Choso is first to intercepted Kenjaku, and
while standing opposite his father he
states his intent to finally end him!
Kenjaku though simply dismisses him as
a dispensable pawn, declaring that the
preparations for the merger between Tengen and the
Japanese civilian population had been completed,
with the culling game now having served
its true purpose. He then also states
that once he gets his hands on Tengen, its
all over, Japan and the world are done for.
We then move into a theatre as Kenjaku shows
his son one version of what could possibly
happen later. If everyone remembers,
during Shibuya n how Yuki mentioned that
optimizing cursed energy through Tengen
will cause non sorcerers to assimilate.
Well Kenjaku adds onto this theory of hers here,
revealing that he believed that to be
the step which preceded the merger,
and unlike Yuki, he didn’t want to
create a world without cursed spirits.
Kenjaku wanted to cause cursed spirits to
evolve to the next stage to create a new
form of cursed energy. So in order to achieve
this he began citing his earlier experiments,
including the creation of Death Painting
wombs, but deemed them all to be too ordinary.
We all know from stuff we've learnt so far that an
evolved Tengen is more cursed spirit than human,
so merging all the non-sorcerers with him
would cause their consciousness to become
one with everyone in Japan. This means,
in Kenjaku’s eyes, that a hundred million
or so people merging together would be able to
create a god level monolith with infinite power.
With the film coming to a close and the realm
changing back to normal. Choso just asks why,
why is he even doing this? to which the
craziest sorcerer alive stated that it
sounds like fun. With Kenjaku tryna drop a joke,
an infuriated Choso claps his hands together
before beginning an attack with piercing blood.
Back in that room before the fight kicked
off, but now with big bro in there,
he tells Yuki and Tengen that he’d
like to face Kenjaku alone. Yuki
though stated that he’ll die if he
did so, to which Choso like the G
he is countered by asking if she would
prefer to fight Kenjaku alongside him.
He admitted that in such a situation, he would
only be a hindrance, so their best bet was for
him to engage Kenjaku in combat and force him
to reveal more about his cursed techniques,
giving Yuki and Tengen an advantage. Yuki states
again that he’ll still die, but Choso insisted
that it did not matter if it allowed them to
end his and his brothers manipulative father.
Flashing back as Choso’s piercing blood shoots
off, Kenjaku watching the approaching attack
manages to easily dodge out of the way of the
attack while releasing a centipede like curse to
attack at his opponent. Having destroyed the curse
along with a large section of the tomb, Choso
watched Kenjaku shoot out in front of him and
fling a large piece of rubble in his direction.
Seeing it Choso screams that he’s underestimating
him, but instantly he’s proven wrong as several
cursed spirits burst out from behind
the thrown piece of concrete. Throwing
a condensed orb of blood forwards himself, Choso
uses Supernova to eviscerate the curse. However;
the cloud provided Kenjaku with a quick opening to
engage the Death Painting in hand-to-hand combat.
After being pushed back and realizing that he was
at a disadvantage, Choso tried to buy some time by
asking how Kenjaku intended to use Yuji since he
was undeniably different from the Death Paintings.
So its explained that Kenjaku doesn't really have
a plan for Yuji other than being Sukuna’s vessel.
Yuji and Sukuna are catalysts, as long as the
two live, the chain of curses will never end.
Choso was enraged by his opponent's conviction
that Yuji was reason for all of this bloodshed
declares that it was Kenjaku whose existence
fuelled the chain of curses, NOT HIS BROTHERS!.
Being taken off guard though Choso looks down
to see some small curses tugging at him, when
all of a sudden Kenjaku takes the opportunity and
pummels his face, sending him spinning backwards.
Instantly following up, he
stomps our boys poor face and
condescendingly declares that he’s only
been using low-level curses on the him,
BUT maybe that was unnecessary since
Choso was so pathetically weak.
Just straight up enraged now, Choso grabs
Kenjaku’s foot but again he gets no where
as he’s quickly slammed back against the
floor. Kenjaku asks the defending curse
womb if he even know what the rank of special
grade even stands for? With Choso unable to
block for any longer the curse over rides
and completely decimates him all the while
this body swapping freak remarks that its the
ability to single-handedly destroy nations…
Those like Satoru and Suguru were special
grades because of their obvious abilities
completely obliterate nations or create
an army of unparalleled monsters.
Kenjaku added that by strengthening pathetically
weak curses with cursed energy he can
easily deal with a failure like Choso.
Laying there our boy berates himself for failing
to be a good older brother to Yuji and his other
siblings. He needed to protect them and be
there to be depend on as that's what a big
brother does.. BUT now he couldn't even land one
hit against his creep of a father. Man this story
with Choso his brother and father reverberates
with me on a different kinda personal level.
Oml Man will never go down, Still AND
like the KING HE IS CHOSO STANDS BACK
UP REFUSING TO EVER LET HIS BROTHERS NAMES
BE DISRESPECTED! SCREAMING!! HE DEMANDS ALL
HIS YOUNGER BROTHER LEND HIM THEIR STRENGTH
AS HE PREPARES TO DELIVER A RAGING ATTACKING!
From behind him Choso all of a sudden begins
to feel the support of his younger brothers
pushing him forward. Eso, Kechizu, and Yuji
assure him that he's got this! Subsequently,
an emotionally overwhelmed Choso begins
attacking Kenjaku using his cursed technique.
Standing there the latter observes that
Piercing Blood’s initial velocity is its
top speed. Dodging the attack he continues
explaining that the ability lost its lethality
once the opponent gets used to its speed and
changing the trajectory will only slow it down.
Watching Kenjaku effortlessly dodge his
attacks, Choso decided to further use an
approximation of Wing King, the most powerful
version of Eso’s Rot Technique. Which if you’ve
forgotten this technique, well when the
lines of blood connect with its target,
they’re instantly burned by the
corrosive effects of their blood.
As Choso darts in throwing a fat right hook,
Kenjaku calls his version of Eso’s technique
just a cheap substitute. However Choso releases
the technique sending 4 beams of blood shooting
towards the body swapping feign. Having summoned
a cursed, Kenjaku backflips out of the way,
using the curse as a shield before sending
a bunch of low level curses towards Choso.
I know this may seem stupid of
a thought, but imagine if Choso,
Yuji and all his brothers were meant to
be one? Kinda like how Panda got merged,
probably is just some random monkey brain
thought im having mid script either way!
Having been hit directly by
Kenjaku’s previous attack,
the latter explains that that Eso’s
ability was not as fast as Piercing
Blood and wouldn't even affect him as he’s
his father… Chilling on a tree branch,
he asks the cursed womb if there was even
a point to everything he’s doing now.
Beaten and bruised Choso declares that
he must fight with the grace of Eso,
the freedom of Kechizu, and domineering
strength of Yuji. Suddenly Kenjaku is
taken off-guard when Choso’s arm fully
detaches and begins blasting towards his
enemy using the connecting blood as a rope.
Using his arm as a gawd damn grappling hook
Choso latches on and pulls the megalomaniac
towards him destroying the ground before
reconnecting his body and UTTERLY PUMMELING
HIS FAT RIGHT HOOK into the face of Kenjaku.
STILL, like bruh mans to quick,
somehow big brain managed to use a
curse to shield himself and lying there
unharmed he asks if his son is done..
Choso with just the fattest grin like mans
entire purpose has been for this moment,
asks the dumbass what he thinks. Releasing another
burst of Eso’s ability he does his best to attack
the fleeing sorcerer. So just if ya didn't
know, our bro, big freaking Choso is actually
Omega third eye level of pre planning and
used his brothers technique to create a
funnel to purposefully trap Kenjaku
within, giving him utterly know where
to run as he releases a few supernova’s
on either side of the malevolent entity…
INSTANTLY Supernova activates destroying the
entire floor all around, only leaving a precise
place where Kenjaku was standing in tact..
Kinda confused, Choso ponders if he missed,
but just knows he activated simultaneous
attacks all around him. Due to this he
quickly deduces that was finally able to get
him to use something OTHER than used spirit
manipulation… FINALLY revealing herself, the
special grade sorcerer Yuki Tsukumo states that
she may be an only child BUT thanks Choso either
way as her ‘older brother’ for all his efforts.
Having heard what Yuki has to say,
Choso faints as relief hits him and falls
through a gap that appears in the barrier.
Looking at her opponent, Yuki states that
she likes it rough, but will have to beat her
opponent into shape. So as I said we know Yuki is
a special grade sorcerer, yet even Kenjaku reveals
that because of the security around her technique
he was was unable to acquire any information.
Unwilling to face a close-range attack from an
unknown technique, Kenjaku decides to maintain
a safe distance and summons the cursed
spirit he had used at the White House.
This cursed spirit here, like I think everyone
presumed isn't even originally from Japan.
Still its actually a special grade divine being
which uses a technique that removes obstacles
by using concepts or logic against cursed
technique targets, more or less its broken.
Yuki interested to see how strong it is, begins
darting forwards while wrapping up her Shikigami,
Garuda, into a ball. Dropping her Shikigami,
Yuki then boots it with all her might sending
it blasting towards the divine curse. From
below, Kenjaku completely blown away can only
watch as his special grade is annihilated
with a single blow. Quickly following up,
Yuki taunts him for being cautious against an
unknown technique, before revealing her ability
revolves around the idea of “mass”. Which,
like we all learnt this in school. Mass is
the true weight of something and to figure out
somethings mass all we gotta do is divide mass
by gravity. So 30kgs x 9.8m/s2^2 = 294 N or
Newtons. but back to what actually matters.
Ferociously she punches Kenjaku in the face,
sending him shooting back across the room. Infact
the blow is so damn strong it not only rips
off both of his arms but also send him flying
across the empty space within Tengen’s barrier
utterly pulverizing any structure in his path.
Its actually shown that Kenjaku was hit so
far that he completely exited the confines of
the barrier. Sitting there Kenjaku realizes
that Yuki uses a specific concept to target
a cursed technique, creating mass overwhelming
enough to obliterate anything in its path.
Yuki just looking like a babe, explains that
she can give herself any amount of virtual or
imaginary “mass,” and calls the technique
Star Rage. Having heard this information,
Kenjaku also deduces that the
virtual mass imbued by Star
Rage doesn't actually affect Yuki as
her speed hasn't decreased at all.
Something super diff about Yuki is the
fact that she defies concepts, meaning
Kenjaku’s completely unable to use a high grade
curse like he had in Shibuya. Looking at her,
the body swapping douche wonders if he
can take down this beast of a sorcerer.
Recognizing that Kenjaku’s
previous ability involved Gravity,
it leaves Yuki convinced that Kenjaku
has at least 3 other techniques besides
Geto’s Curse Manipulation and
his body-hopping technique.
She doubts that that he has many more as well, as
without an external aid like Yuta Okkotsu’s Rika,
the users brain would explode under such strain.
She guesses that in the worst-case scenario,
Kenjaku has yet another unknown
4th technique up his sleeve.
Opposing her, Kenjaku deduces that Yuki’s
special-grade rank suggests that she probably
has a high cursed-energy output extension
technique which she’ll use as her trump card.
So Yuki’s plan here is that she’s going to force
Kenjaku to use Domain Expansion, which as we all
know, will make it difficult for him to use
his multiple cursed techniques afterwards.
In the end she decides to systematically
weaken Kenjaku’s domain before striking
the final blow… BUT THAT ISNT WHATS
GOING TO HAPPEN. IF YOU THINK OUR
GUYS PLANS EVER WORK OUT IN JUJUTSU
KAISEN, YOU ARE SMOKING YOURSELF.
THIS IS KENJAKU’s WORLD…
He knows they find each other tricky,
but unlike Yuki he doesn't lack the
confidence to unleash pure dominance.
Having moved his hands together,
Kenjaku releases his Domain Expansion,
the barrierless WOMB PROFUSION. INSTANTLY,
Yuki screams out to Tengen wondering
if there’s still enough time!
Taking things back a moment,
Tengen explained that during
the battle they would confront Kenjaku in
a labyrinthine barrier located directly
below the cursed warehouse and just
above the tomb of the star corridor.
Each room inside of this labyrinthine barrier
is empty. This allows a skilled sorcerer,
say for this example Kenjaku to be able to alter
its structure, or at least that's what they would
want him to think as if that's the case then hell
most likely feel comfortable and lowers his guard.
The reason they need him to feel
comfortable, is so that he’ll
non-chalantly use a Domain Expansion within
Tengen’s empty barrier. If this is the case,
then Tengen who’s extremely proficient at barrier
control (obviously) would under the condition Yuki
can hold Kenjaku off for ten seconds, be able
to manipulate and dispel the feigns domain.
So obviously Yuki could've used her Domain
Expansion, but using it during that time
would also cause her domain to be dispelled, as
that's literally their plan here with Tengen.
Instead to protect herself from Kenjaku,
she had planned to use a Simple Domain.
Yuki pondered if using her domain would
be a more efficient way of forcing their
opponent to open his domain. However,
Tengen reasoned that her domain would
be dispelled first as its technically
the outer layer and might also give
Kenjaku the opportunity to counter with
a Simple Domain or Hollow Wicker Basket.
Lastly he warned her that Kenjaku is one
of the very few people who can equal him
in barrier usage, so don't assume that his domain
is like everyone else's..… (Foreshadowing baby)
Yet, Kenjaku’s true potential was even
higher than Tengen ever suspected. As
just like ‘the goat’ Sukuna during
Shibuya, the body swapping genius
cast a barrierless domain leaving no outer
boundary for Tengen to remove at all.
Instantly in retaliation to the domain, Yuki’s
cast her New Shadow Style: Simple Domain, However,
almost immediately and due to Kenjaku not having
a barrier on his domain, Tengen's technique begins
stripping away Yuki’s shell. With no other
option, she sprints forth in an attempt to
take down Kenjaku. Slowly Tengen began stripping
away the body swappers structureless barrier..
However, Kenjaku remained unfazed, screams
that, unlike the TENGEN, he has "lived" for
over a thousand years in a cursed world rife with
conflicts and alliances. THEN OUT OF FREAKING
KNOW WHERE, Yuki who’s left with no defences is
rocked by the pure force that is gravity pounding
down on her, sending her shooting through the
floor of Tengen's empty labyrinthine barrier.
Now in the Tomb of The Star Corridor and with Yuki
completely crushed, Kenjaku states that had the
special-grade sorcerer used her domain instead
of relying on an old fool, she might have fared
better. Man this old dude must have no friends
cause HOLY he loves talking, he even further
barks on that Tengen had hidden a vital piece
of information regarding the Culling G- yet bro
cant even finish his sentence as he notices
Yuki’s Shikigami still hasn't disappeared.
Instantly shooting at him, Garuda destroys the
area around Kenjaku forcing him back. Kenjaku
guessed that the sorcerer was trying to buy
herself enough time to heal herself using RTC.
However, man is just completely wrong as Yuki
looking like she was in a washing machine for
24 hours still somehow continued to attack
relentlessly, disregarding her injuries and
giving the villain no chance to recover. Kenjaku
just blown away asks why she isn't healing,
but Yuki just doesn't care and continued
her assault with a maniacal smile.
Continuing, Yuki like a pure demon kicks
and lashes at the ancient sorcerer,
until it seemed as if she may have finally
reached her limit dropping to the floor.
Kenjaku asked if that was it? leading Yuki to
ask if the villain had forgotten her declaration,
SHE LIKES IT ROUGH. RIGHT ON QUE que the
big man himself, Choso returns to the fight,
entering the empty barrier from behind
Kenjaku with his technique fully activated.
Doing the GEGE we skip away as per usual
going back to just before the battle broke
out. The Death Painting reasoned that
domains neutralized cursed techniques,
so Kenjaku wouldn't open his domain
if he expected Choso to join the
fight later meaning that he should
as he mentioned before, fight first.
He suggested that he face off against the mad-man
first, fooling him into believing that his only
opponent for the rest of the fight was Yuki, then
he’d re appear. Back in the battle and completely
stunned, Kenjaku is immediately restrained by
Garuda weighing him down. Firmly landing on
the ground, Choso slaps his hands together and
tells his brothers to watch, as their big bro
is about to commit patricide. INSTANT our boy used
Piercing Blood on his dad at a point-blank range.
YET, like bruh how’d ya brain dodge
that even Yuki and Choso are blown
away as they both get a glimpse of
Kenjaku’s true form. Yuki observed
that the villain had spun his head open
deliberately to deflect the attack.
She concluded that Kenjaku was desperate
enough to use such a move because he was
also becoming troubled. Knowing this,
the duo keep up their heated beatdown
attacking in tandem, laying fat kicks,
punches and elbows on the sorcerer.
Using her RTC, Yuki easily manages to
fix her mangled arm and other injuries,
but the momentary distraction weakened Star
Rage just enough to allow Kenjaku to escape.
Wielding Garuda like a whip, Yuki swings
at Kenjaku only just missing but the energy
released utterly demolishes the floor and walls
of the Star Corridor around them. With everyone
falling down onto some water below, Choso
uses the falling debris as a smokescreen
to ambush his opponent. While simultaneously
Yuki lets loose another attack using her Star
Rage-imbued cursed tool. Caught off-guard
themselves though, both Choso and Garuda
drop to the floor under the weight of Kenjaku’s
overwhelming gravity and replenished technique.
Yuki’s Shikigami lashes out trying to move but
is unable under the gravity and while Yuki runs
in to collect it she deduces how this technique
works. She concludes that the ancient sorcerer’s
attacks have had a radius of two or three
meters, and remained activated for six seconds.
Swinging her Garuda at him, she knows that
once he’s caught something within his gravity
trap Kenjaku will then finish it off with a
cursed spirit. But she doubt that even that
will work against her as she’s not gonna
stop until she beats him down and wins.
Though she should've just won and not internalized
it, as Kenjaku was able to parry off a vicious
head punch before grabbing Yuki’s arm and
directing a miniature Uzumaki at her face.
With her completely fried from a point blank
blast, Yuki begins to dart backwards. When all
of a sudden Kenjaku follows up and forms another
miniature Uzumaki while remarking that her density
increased may have increased due to Star Rage, but
her tensile strength didn’t. Releasing the attack,
Kenjaku leaves Choso screaming in horror as his
attack tears straight through Yuki’s abdomen.
Really damn abruptly we again fly into
flashback our team sitting at a bar.
There Yuki asked Choso if he
didn’t want to be there for Yuji,
since it seemed like he was throwing his life
away now. Not answering the questing tho,
Choso asks if he’s even human. He remembers
thinking back to the time when his brothers
took form and realized that they would
never be accepted by humans because of
their deformed looks. So from this, Choso
decided to live as curse with his brothers,
hence why he killed so many people in Shibuya
and why now he burdens himself with their deaths.
Saddened with his choices, big bro states
that if he had chosen to live as a human,
he wouldn't have lost them. Weeping
he wonders why he chose the easy path,
was it because he didn't want to see his
brothers suffering as humans. Then a human
who just happened to be suffering showed up… The
four were meant to fight together as brothers,
but instead he took the easy
road and left Yuji all alone…
Returning to the battle Choso gearing
up to unleash a spinning wheel of blood
at the enemy states that the only way to
make it up to them all is to use all his
life here. But before he could release the
attack, Tengen forcibly removed him from the
barrier. Yuki looking like Gojo fr tells
him that this battlefield was where the
Death Painting’s life as a curse ended and his
time as a human has begun, so he must live.
Above the falling Choso, Yuki’s body also falls
to the ground in two with her seemingly defeated
by Kenjaku’s previous blow. Behind the two
though, Tengen reveals themselves causing Kenjaku
to actually laugh at the thumbs appearance,
even comparing him to Sukuna’s original form.
Tengen is like dude check your kills all
I had to do was distract you for 2 damn
seconds allowing Yuki’s top half, like
girl is just built different, to grab
the villain’s cankle. Not taking her seriously
though, Kenjaku tells her to die before all of
a sudden and out of know where, a massive force
begins ripping the sorcerer down towards Yuki.
As I said at some point earlier, Yuki’s
technique’s alterations in mass don't
affect her.. Up to a certain density that
is. You see and remember when I mentioned
what makes a Special Grade. Well nothing
you’ve seen so far would actually give our
girl that ranking. Like yeah she's insane, but
this next technique is what makes her a threat
to every freaking LIFEFORM ON THIS PLANET. When
Yuki goes beyond her max density control point,
the sorcerer can add an infinite amount of
mass with her cursed technique and if you
somehow haven't caught on YES, she can create
a gawd damn black hole. The end result was the
creation of a black hole, which not only consumed
Yuki’s own body but trapped all matter and even
light in it. Right before disappearing, Yuki
declared that he should’ve seen this coming,
gravity, mass, and time all needed
to be wielded with extreme caution.
With the black hole formed, it begins
sucking in literally everything from the
surrounding area including the Tombs of the Star
Corridor, debris from the nearby floors, walls,
and surrounding buildings. As the energy from
the black hole finally began to subside even
the ceiling of the tombs began crumbling away,
with natural light breaking through and
lighting up the underground chambers.
Rip Yuki
Despite the immense gravitational
force exerted by the black hole,
Kenjaku somehow manages to climbing out from under
the collapsed debris. Stunned, Tengen asked if he
had used the Reverse Cursed Technique in
combination with his gravity technique.
But Kenjaku made a shocking revelation, declaring
that the true nature of the technique had not been
gravity at all. He admitted that his third cursed
technique originally belonged to Yuji’s mother,
Kaori Itadori, with its true form being the
Anti-Gravity System. The body-hopping sorcerer
added that he had taken a risky gamble and used
Lapse to reverse the effects of the technique,
stabilizing the output and activation time by
using his own body as a domain. Like I said THIS
IS KENJAKU’s WORLD mans pre planned everything
for a millennia idk how they gonna win here boys.
Like the famous JJK scholar Broken Ronin
once said, every word in this series has
merit. So think on this, Kenjaku
as he watches Tengen's apparition
disappearing he states this was just a warm
up. Then finding the latter’s actual body,
encased within the trunk of a tree in the Star
Corridor. Kenjaku says goodbye to his friend.
N like I just said, think on those words
boys, what do you think? let me know below,
were they friends back in the day? What
is Kenjaku to Tengen? Plus everything,
all the revelations that happen in this arc
are mind boggling, Sukuna had 4 eyes why
did Kenjaku specifically bring the relation
up. HHHHMMM, I feel like the whole culling
game is just mind boggling right now. Either
way I hope you all enjoyed the video and if
you want more stuff just like this but for a
variety of different series then let me know
down below. Plus leave a like push this video
to a fat 5k likes and ill try do a backflip,
but till then for now's been ya professional
degenerate and ill see ya in a bit. Bye!